- [Voice Over] Today on Couch Tomatoes,
we're talking all things Emmys.
- I'll tell you one thing,
if we lose it certainly won't be for
lack of touching people in a Denny's.
Hello everybody!
- What's up everyone?
I'm Naz Perez
and welcome to the brand-new
show from Rotten Tomatoes,
Couch Tomatoes.
Brought to you by Freschetta.
Here's the thing,
with TV and all these
new streaming services,
it's so hard to choose what to watch on TV
because there's so many
good options out there.
Which is why here on Couch Tomatoes
we're gonna help you guys out.
And we're actually kicking
off our first episode
talking all things Emmys,
because the Emmys are this Sunday.
And lucky for me, I'm
not doing this alone.
Joining me on the couch today is
senior editor at TV Guide,
Malcolm Venable.
- Hey.
- Fandango's Film and TV
correspondent Nikki Novak.
And IndieWire's Ben Travers.
Hello guys!
- [Nikki] Hi.
- [Malcolm] Hello.
- I feel I have the Golden
State Warriors of the Emmys.
(guests laugh) You know what I mean?
You guys watch so much television.
I can't wait to hear your predictions.
Before we get into predictions though,
I really want to talk
about the big stories
that everyone's talking
about when it comes to Emmys.
Starting with 'Game of Thrones,' right?
I mean, a whopping 32 Emmy nominations.
They already stole 10 of
them this past weekend
at the Creative Arts Emmys.
However, they had a
controversial last season, right?
58% on the Tomatometer.
Think the series average
is 89% on the Tomatometer.
A lot of people feel like
the final season was rushed.
We saw caramel macchiatos on set.
So Ben, I want to start off with you.
Do you feel like this final season
is gonna taint 'Games of Thrones'' legacy?
Or do you feel like
the Emmy voters are actually
gonna honor 'Game of Thrones'?
- I think it's both.
I think the final season
kinda tainted its own legacy,
but in terms of The Emmys,
they're gonna give it
all the awards still.
They're so locked in at this point
because there's just not a lot
of strong competition out there.
Like, the other shows are great,
but they're not as beloved.
They're not as instilled
within the academy
as 'Game of Thrones.'
So they're still gonna
make a run on Sunday
and it's gonna be a lot of wins.
- There's a lot of shows that also
wouldn't qualify this season.
Like 'Westworld.'
We didn't see 'Handmaid's Tale.'
A lot of shows,
and 'The Crown,'
that we would normally
see go up against them,
and I think that's part of the reason
we saw more nominations.
- Yeah, there's still
nothing like it on television
in terms of scope and scale
and production and story.
- Do you guys feel like Emmy voters
tend to favor final seasons?
- I think they do
when it's the right
kind of timing, I guess.
You've seen it happen with
stuff like 'Breaking Bad.'
They got really, really
excited for those final,
that final season, slash two
split seasons of 'Breaking Bad'
and they really wanted to give it
as many awards as they possibly could,
despite a lot of intense
competition out there.
But 'Mad Men''s final
season was widely ignored.
John Hamm was able to pull off a win
because he just hadn't done it yet.
- [Naz] Right.
- [Ben] But they felt like
they'd honored it so many times already
that they were kinda done with it.
- I feel like now that it's
been a couple of months
since the last episode
and people's madness has
sort of cooled off a bit.
It's the writers that
people are mad at primarily.
Not necessarily the actors
and I think that's where you're gonna see,
I'm even hearing words,
like the word sweep.
This week.
That there could be a
sweep of 'Game of Thrones.'
So I think that people are
sort of getting behind it again
and want to see,
it was a cultural phenomenon.
You're not gonna see anything
like it for a long time,
if ever.
- Thank heaven.
(everyone laughs)
- Are you tired of it?
- I'm not a Throner.
I mean, it's fine.
I'm like, who are all these people?
I don't know all their names.
- He admits it!
I love that you're admitting this!
- Yeah, this is better
than watching football.
I'm like, I don't know
who these people are
under the helmets.
But what's interesting
about the final season
of 'Game of Thrones,'
and you were mentioning madness,
is that when HBO was
getting a lot of flak
for this final season,
'Chernobyl' kinda came up out of nowhere
and was this instant success for HBO.
And it got me thinking
about the next big story at Emmys
that everyone's talking about
which is lead actor in a limited series,
where Jared Harris from
'Chernobyl' is actually nominated.
When I look at this category,
it's really insane you guys.
You have all these Oscar winners,
Benicio Del Toro, Mahershala
Ali, Sam Rockwell.
All up for their first Emmy ever.
But really the buzz is around
Jharrel Jerome and Jared Harris.
So, Malcolm, I wanna hear from you first.
Do these two stand a chance
against these seasoned actors?
- Absolutely.
But I think it's gonna go to Jharrel.
I mean, he's just 21, which is remarkable.
He did such a phenomenal
job in 'When They See Us.'
But I think there's specific things
that work in his favor
from that performance.
The story is timely.
It's about social justice.
He was the only person in the cast
to play a younger version
of the same person.
- [Naz] Right.
- And then he had a
entire episode to himself,
where he was in solitary confinement,
and he just really kind of
broke out of the confines
of what you even expect
to see on television.
It was just fantastic.
If he doesn't win, I'm rioting.
I'm fighting.
I'm putting that out there.
- I'm putting it out there
that someone with the
letter J is gonna win
(everyone laughs) this category.
No, I think it's between the two.
And I think even though we have legends,
I think it's
social relevance and buzz.
And 'Chernobyl' and When
'They See Us' have that.
So between the two, I keep going,
this is one of my toughest categories.
When we get to the predictions
I still don't know what I'm gonna say.
It's gonna be either Jared or Jharrel.
- Yeah.
In terms of the Oscar winners out there
I really think Mahershala Ali
is the leader of that squadron of folk.
I think he delivered
such an incredible
performance on 'True Detective.'
But at the same time,
I feel like,
we've given it to Mahershala before.
He's won two Oscars now.
He's very well-known, very respected.
I think it's probably time
to share the wealth a little bit.
And I think people are really excited,
especially given how many nominations,
when they see who else is
in the acting categories,
to award someone from that cast,
and Jharrel's the man.
- Yeah, and I think a couple years ago,
if a film actor did a TV show,
we kinda assumed they
were gonna win the Emmy,
and I don't think we're
necessarily seeing that anymore.
- Right, which is crazy.
But you brought up something
that got me thinking.
Between Jharrel and Jared,
because I'm also torn between these two.
There's this kind of
generational struggle here.
Do you award someone who's
been at it for a while,
who gave us a stand-out performance?
Or do you award the person
with his breakthrough performance
so early on in his acting career?
- I still say Jharrel.
It gives the Emmys an opportunity
to be, for lack of a better word,
hipper and cooler.
Because Jharrel's a kid.
- Got it.
- He's not even 22 yet.
- But Jared Harris, I will argue,
he is sort of an unsung hero.
He has been around for so long
and hasn't necessarily got the accolades
as some of the bigger
stars in this category.
- He was nominated for 'Mad Man'
and a lot of people were actually upset
that he wasn't nominated for first season
of AMC's 'The Terror,' so.
- Yeah.
So I think it would be one of those things
where if he did win,
I don't think
anybody would be necessarily mad at that
because he does have that body of work.
And hasn't been a name,
he's been in so many things
and he's that person
that's just not a big star.
But he's deserving.
- And weirdly enough, it feels like,
you mentioned,
he's broken out on TV already.
And he's had enough roles through 'Mad Men,'
through 'The Terror,' through 'The Crown,'
where it's like he should
have been recognized
more than he has been with the Emmys,
which makes me think
that they're just not
as big a fans perhaps
as the rest of the world.
Or at least the rest of the TV community.
- Well one person they're not slow for is
Miss Julia Louis-Dreyfus.
I mean, next to the word
Emmy winner in the dictionary
I feel is her face.
But before we get to Julia,
Nikki and I actually sat down earlier
to talk about all the must-haves you need
for an awards-worthy watch party.
Check it out.
All right guys,
so aside from hooking you
up with all our predictions,
we're also gonna tell you how to spice up
your award show watch party this weekend.
- I'm actually having one at my place.
I need a little help with this.
What do you think that I should serve?
- OK, so whenever I have a party
I always serve pizza
because you can't go wrong with pizza.
It makes the party.
- If somebody doesn't like pizza,
I don't like them.
- [Naz] Yeah! No, I agree.
And when I throw a party,
my go-to is Freschetta.
Because they have so
many different flavors.
They're just made better.
And this rising crust
pepperoni is always a hit.
- It looks amazing.
- Yeah, people are obsessed with it.
- I'm set for that.
So now I'm thinking pairings.
I know red wine always
goes well with pizza,
but what do you think?
Champagne, cocktails?
- I think it's fun to switch it up.
I think people forget
that pizza goes so well
with so many different drink pairings.
My personal favorite pizza with champagne
is actually this brick
oven spinach and mushroom.
- Diving in.
- There's something about the
earthiness of the mushroom
that just goes so well with the rich,
fruitiness of the Champagne.
When I'm throwing a party
I always like to elevate the experience
and I throw a little gin, lemon, and sugar
in the Champagne.
It's called a French 75.
And that is also always a hit.
- You are so fancy.
You really need
to come to my party.
- I try.
- You're invited.
- Oh my God, thanks!
If you're serving Freschetta
and Champagne, I'm there.
- Yay! Cheers.
- Cheers.
Okay, let's talk about
Julia Louis-Dreyfus.
I feel like she has more
gold statues in her house
than the city of Dubai.
She could soon hold
the most Emmys for a
performer of all time.
She's currently tied with
Cloris Leachman for eight.
Nikki, does anyone stand a chance
against Julia in the lead
actress for a comedy series?
- I think this is the biggest lock
of everything at the Emmys.
But it's so much of a lock,
that it's reminding me of
Glenn Close at the Oscars.
How everybody thought she was gonna win,
but then there was a shock
when Olivia Colman won.
So that's the only thing I think.
Barring a shocking moment like that,
I think she's a lock.
I think she's been a superstar
through this whole thing.
I think if they're gonna award the show
for their last season,
it might not necessarily go to 'Veep,'
but Julia will be the
person that's gonna win.
- Yeah, and I mean
I think over the last few years
when 'Veep' was a sure thing
in a lot of categories,
that it felt even more like Julia was,
she was gonna take it.
You just wrote that off.
You didn't worry about it.
But because it's a little
bit weaker this year
because other comedies
have more nominations
than HBO's crown jewel,
maybe this is the year
where Julia finally slips off.
Maybe this is the time
when Phoebe Waller-Bridge
sneaks in for 'Fleabag.'
Or Natasha Lyonne sneaks
in for 'Russian Doll.'
Both of those got some
Creative Arts Emmy love
this past weekend,
which was really exciting.
You know, it could happen.
I'm still with you,
I still think Julia's got it,
but I'm a little more nervous than normal.
- Well you know, I say
when it comes to the Emmys
it's like Jan Brady's,
"Julia, Julia, Julia."
It's hers.
Does Miss Brosnahan have a chance her?
She did one last year when
Julia wasn't eligible.
- If it was a should win category
I would choose Rachel.
Because I think she continues
to excel on that show.
But I think that show will clean up
but I don't necessarily,
what?
- [Ben] Sorry.
I can't get on board with this nonsense.
This is,
this is a lot.
- Nonsense?
Over Phoebe?
- I would put Rachel like
fourth or fifth billed
on just charge of deserving winner.
- Yeah, this go round.
It's Julia and then Phoebe.
- In terms of what you feel or would.
- It's Phoebe and then Julia.
- Well then we can't leave
out Catherine O'Hara too,
because--
- Well, Catherine O'Hara.
- [Nikki] Moira Rose.
I mean,
- [Nikki] How is no one even
talking about Catherine?
- [Malcolm] And this will be her second
since like 1980,
she hasn't won since 1982
or something like that.
And she's such a beloved character.
Not that the other ones aren't,
but I mean.
- But is this a viable--
- Moira Rose is iconic.
- Is an iconic TV character.
I'm shocked that more people
aren't talking about.
- I think people are though.
I think in terms of an upset,
that name is getting bounced around
as much as Phoebe's name is.
And I think that's another person
that if she were to win,
people would jump to their feet.
- Absolutely.
- It would just be a huge moment.
- Although Julia might hit her,
beat her in the parking lot or something.
(everyone laughs)
- As Selina or as herself? (laughs)
- I wanna take a second
and talk about first time nominees
and some fresh faces.
Who are some first time nominees
that you think people should
be paying attention to?
- I'm team Jharrel Jerome.
Again, we know him from his
outstanding turn in 'Moonlight.'
Which seems like ancient history
when it was only a couple
of years ago. (laughs)
And to think he's this
young kid from the Bronx
who actually never even thought
that he'd be able to become an actor.
I mean, so many boxes get checked here.
He's fantastic for
representation of Latin and
African American performances.
This story is timely relevant.
Socially conscious.
The material that he had to work with
is obviously outstanding.
- Nikki?
- I concur.
But I'm gonna throw
in an Anthony Carrigan.
I absolutely
love him on 'Barry.'
It is one of my favorite shows.
But that character, NoHo Hank,
he's such a standout.
Every time he comes on screen,
as much as I love the other actors,
he steals every scene he's in.
And I think he's pretty much a long-shot
in terms of a win,
but I'm so glad he was nominated.
- And he's making no eyebrows
look fabulous. (everyone laughs)
- Yes!
That's hard to do,
because I've had that before.
- It's hard to do.
- And trust me,
the alien look is not good.
- I'm waiting for thin
eyebrows to come back,
so I can be in again.
- And mine is Jodie Comer for 'Killing Eve.'
Who I just feel like is on fire right now.
We're just kinda waiting
with baited breath
to see what else she's gonna get to do.
Because she's so good on 'Killing Eve.'
And creating an assassin in 2019
who's unique and stands out
and that people wanna keep watching
and are interested in
and doesn't just fit the
mold of previous characters,
she's done that and then so much more.
- I'm just throwing out there,
she should be a Marvel superhero.
I think she would make a great--
- That is such a great--
- She's new, she's fresh.
She's a great actress.
And she has a presence.
- As far as fresh faces for me,
I'm really into Joey King right now.
What she did in 'The Act,'
the physical transformation
to shaving her head,
I feel like she gave us such a deep
and mature performance
and we're so used to seeing her
in these kid and teen-friendly movies
like 'The Kissing Booth' on Netflix.
And just the video that she
uploaded on social media
when she got nominated,
it actually made me cry.
I'm really excited for
her that she's nominated,
and I just can't wait to
see what she does next.
- She reminds me of a Natalie Portman.
Like how she was a young
actress that you just knew
was gonna be a massive
actress when she got older.
She's that person.
Yeah.
- OK guys,
so I feel we got through
all the big stories.
We got through all the first time nominees
that we think you guys
should watch out for.
But now I want to go
through each major category
and know who your predictions are.
Because I have a car payment to pay off
and I'm gonna be making
some bets this weekend.
(Malcolm chuckles)
So I wanna hear who
you guys predict to win
and then after you guys tell me
I'm actually gonna tell you guys
what the RT staff pick is.
And so these are the expect predictions
for the nominees on TV's biggest night,
based on the combined ballots
of the editorial team
here at Rotten Tomatoes.
So, first one
Lead Actress in a Comedy Series.
We obviously talked about this
when we talked about Julia.
But I wanna know down the line,
who do you guys think is
gonna win this weekend?
- Julia.
- Julia, Julia, Julia!
- And Julia!
- She's like Tom Brady
at a Super Bowl right now!
(everyone laughs)
She's just a shoe-in.
And surprise, surprise guys,
the RT staff pick is
also Julia Louis-Dreyfus,
so I will be shocked if she
doesn't win this Sunday.
- I think she will too.
(everyone laughs)
- Okay, so Lead Actor in a Comedy Series.
When I look at this category
I think there's a lot of showbiz
legends in this category.
You've got Ted Danson,
Michael Douglas,
Eugene Levy.
And then you have Bill Hader,
who's nominated again.
Won this category last year.
So who do you guys predict to win?
- Bill, again.
- Bill Hader's gonna win this.
He's the IT guy.
The IT movie.
And he is the IT guy of the season.
- Yeah, they're not done
rewarding Bill Hader just yet.
He's gonna win.
- OK.
Well the RT staff pick also
thinks it's Bill Hader.
So, hopefully he takes that.
Okay, so Outstanding Comedy Series.
And I wanna make note that no show
that's won for its first season
has ever won for its final season.
'cause I feel like a lot of people
are looking at 'Veep,' right?
'cause it's the final season.
So who do you guys predict to win
Outstanding Comedy on Sunday?
- So, I think 'Veep' is gonna win,
although I'd like 'Fleabag' to win,
'Veep' will win.
- All right.
- I disagree.
I don't think it's gonna be Veep.
I think 'Veep' only has, I
think eight total nominations?
I think 'The Marvelous Mrs. Maisel'
is flying under the radar,
just because we kinda go,
"OK, we've heard it, we've heard it."
But I really think that 20
nominations are impressive.
But I think 'Marvelous
Mrs. Maisel' is gonna win.
- I was actually team 'Barry'
up until the Creative Arts Awards,
and then after 'Maisel' just
kinda dominated that scene
in a way that we didn't expect,
I'm starting to come onto the 'Maisel' side,
and officially I'm gonna go 'Maisel.'
- Did I just win you over?
- Yeah.
(everyone laughs)
- The RT staff pick, guys, is 'Fleabag.'
And I also think 'Fleabag' is gonna take it.
I think 'Fleabag' is gonna do an upset.
- Thank you for validating me.
(everyone laughs)
- OK, let's move on to
Lead Actress in a Limited Series.
This category is very interesting, right?
Patricia Arquette won the
Globe for 'Escape at Dannemora,'
but this time Michelle
Williams is in the mix.
Who do you guys have winning
Lead Actress in a Limited Series?
- I say Michelle Williams.
It has to.
It's just a phenomenal performance,
and on top of that,
I think
the story that is running tangent
to the actual show has been great.
So I think Michelle
Williams is the winner.
- Nikki?
- I have nothing more to add,
so I concur about Michelle Williams,
but I need to give a
shout out to Amy Adams.
She will not win,
but she was so outstanding
in 'Sharp Objects'
- It's gonna be Michelle.
She's got so much love around town.
Like, the response that
people have shown her
for during the FYC screenings,
during her campaigning around town.
It's been overwhelming,
and I think she's gonna take it.
- I think she's so deserving of it too.
And the RT staff pick agrees.
Michelle Williams for 'Fosse/Verdon.'
OK, Lead Actor in a Limited Series.
We kinda talked about this
at the top of the show.
We didn't really talk
about Hugh Grant too much.
It was there for 'A Very English Scandal,'
and then kind of just went away.
Who do you guys predict to
win this category this Sunday?
- Jharrel.
- Jharrel Jerome.
- This is the toughest one for me.
But I'm going with Jharrel.
- I'm going with Jharrel as well.
I feel like he's captured
the momentum at this point,
and also they love that show.
- It would be so epic to see him win, too.
Over all these seasoned
actors in the category.
But the RT staff pick actually thinks
it's gonna go to Jared
Harris for 'Chernobyl.'
- [Malcolm] Ooh.
- Which I would also be
happy to see him take that.
Okay, let's talk about
Outstanding Limited Series.
We kinda talked about this
at the top of the show.
When I look at this category,
all of these shows are
based on real life events,
except for 'Sharp Objects.'
And I feel like the race
here is really between
'Chernobyl' and 'When They See Us.'
Both powerful stories that
portray these great injustices
that came out of woeful ignorance.
Who do you guys predict
to win this Sunday?
- I say 'When They See Us.'
You know, we've talked about
the social injustice aspect
but it's also really well done.
- This was the trickiest one for me.
It was so, so tough.
It's so neck and neck.
And I really had 'When They See Us,'
but with the Creative Arts Emmys,
'Chernobyl' just upped
the anti a little bit.
I think it has the slight edge right now.
But it could go either way.
I'd be happy with either,
but I think it's gonna be 'Chernobyl.'
- I actually agree with you
in the sense that I think
'Chernobyl' has the edge right now,
but I'm sticking with 'When They See Us.'
- So Nikki, the RT staff pick
actually agrees with you.
And they're going with 'Chernobyl.'
So this will be a really fun
category to watch on Sunday.
OK, moving on to Lead
Actress in a Drama Series.
This category has a
staggering seven nominees.
Ben, you kinda talked about
this at the top of the show.
I feel like the race here is
between Sandra Oh and Jodie.
For the same show.
So who do you guys predict?
- Sandra.
- Sandra Oh.
- I like Jodie better this season,
but she didn't win before.
And this is a historic moment for her.
And for
women of Asian descent as well.
Not that that's the thing that's
gonna carry her necessarily
but she still did a phenomenal job
so I'm going with Sandra.
- I'm actually gonna go outside
of the box a little bit.
I'm gonna go with Emilia Clark.
I think it's gonna be a surprise
there for 'Game of Thrones.'
I think she's so beloved.
I think she's been nominated
before, several times.
And I think,
this is the last chance
for her to get this win.
So I think it's gonna be her.
- If that's the win,
then that's the one I'll riot for.
So while you're rioting for Jharrel,
I'll be very angry if Emilia wins,
especially because Sandra and Jodie
are just so good in 'Killing Eve.'
Yeah, I think it's Sandra.
- Oh, well it's interesting
because the RT staff pick
also think it's Sandra.
But Sandra has also never won an Emmy.
- Yeah!
- It's crazy!
Okay, let's move onto Lead
Actor in a Drama Series.
This category is really interesting
because Billy Porter is
the only first time nominee
yet I'm hearing a lot of buzz about him.
What do you guys predict?
- Yeah, it's Billy Porter.
And he deserves it.
And I think it's been so great to see
his campaigning for it.
And the ways he talks about
having been overlooked
as a performer for most of his career.
And now to be in a position
where he's the lead.
I think people love it.
And have great feelings
about the show and him.
So I'd say Billy's the winner.
- What do you think?
- I agree.
I think it's Billy's.
I think Billy is by far the frontrunner
in this category.
- I think it's a little
bit closer than that.
I do think that Jason
Bateman has a shot for 'Ozark,'
but I am gonna go with Billy Porter.
I think 'Pose' has that slight edge.
- And guys, surprise surprise,
the RT staff pick is also
for Billy Porter for 'Pose.'
So I really hope we see
him win this this Sunday.
Moving onto the big one,
Outstanding Drama Series.
Do we still think it's gonna be 'GOT'?
- Yeah.
- Yeah?
- It's definitely 'Game of Thrones.'
- If you want to get your new car...
(everyone laughs)
- Put it on 'Game of Thrones'?
- That's gonna be the one, yeah.
- Yeah, again, your odds
are gonna be terrible.
But I would bet the
car on 'Game of Thrones.'
I think if there's an upset lurking,
which there isn't,
it would be 'Succession.'
If only because it's gained so much buzz
for its second season.
And people have really picked
up on it a little bit late.
And maybe enough people like it
and HBO wants to see it.
But it's not gonna happen.
It's still gonna be 'Game of Thrones.'
- Okay, and the RT staff pick also agrees
that it's gonna be 'Game of Thrones.'
So guys, thank you so much
for all your predictions.
Hopefully we got all of you
guys back at home set up
so you're ready to go on Sunday.
But before we go,
I wanna talk to you guys
about what your fresh picks are.
So these are shows that
are nominated for an Emmy,
but maybe are a little
bit under the radar.
So what show do you think everyone
should add to their watch list?
- I'd say 'Twilight Zone.'
Kumail Nanjiani is nominated
for his performance
in the first episode of the new
CBS All Access take on the series.
And he plays this stand up comedian
who's in this warped, demented universe
where he has the ability
to make people die
with his routine.
And I thought it was fantastic.
- I want to have that ability.
(everyone laughs)
- Is that not what we're doing right now?
I thought we were deciding the Emmys
as we said no to some and yes to others.
- My pick, you just mentioned.
'Succession.'
A minute into it, I
was hooked on the show.
But, if people for whatever
reason, haven't stuck with it
episode five is when it really kicks in.
And it goes to another level.
Do you agree with me
on that one?
- Yeah I do.
- It goes to another level.
And also, season two.
The most highly addictive show.
If you want to get less sleep,
watch that show.
(everyone laughs)
- What a recommendation.
Sleep less.
But no, my fresh pick is
actually 'Big Mouth' on Netflix.
A new season is just around the corner.
It was nominated for
Best Animated Program.
It's co-created by Nick Kroll
as well as a slew of other people.
It's got a great voice cast.
Maya Rudolph absolutely
owns the whole thing.
She pops up in just the most amazing ways
and the way she says bubble
bath, you'll never forget.
(everyone laughs)
- I'm going with 'Fosse/Verdon.'
Because I love Broadway, you guys,
but I never knew the
behind the scenes stories
of Bob Fosse and Gwen Verdon.
We talked about Michelle Williams,
she is so unreal in this.
I was watching the
episodes and I was like,
"Can someone get a Tony Award
"for a theatrical performance on screen?"
Asking for Michelle Williams.
It is just so good.
FX series produced by Lin-Manuel Miranda,
and I feel like a lot of
people didn't watch it.
I think it came out right before
season eight of 'Game of Thrones.'
So I feel like it got lost in the shuffle
with all the amazing limited series,
but I just love, love, love 'Fosse/Verdon.'
All right guys, well that's our show.
That's all the time we have for today.
I wanna thank you guys so much.
I feel like we covered so much ground
when it comes to Emmys.
If you guys wanna see a
full list of predictions
from Rotten Tomatoes,
head over to rottentomatoes.com.
Also let us know in the comments section,
what your thoughts and
what your predictions are.
If you agree or disagree with us.
We really wanna hear from you guys.
And don't forget
to hit that subscribe button
and notification bell.
It is free, and you won't
miss any future episode
of Couch Tomatoes.
Thank you so much for tuning
into the first episode.
The first one we're doing is
'American Horror Story 1984.'
I am so excited.
Thank you to Malcolm, Nikki, and Ben
for joining me today guys.
- Great.
- Woo!
- I'm Naz Prez, and we'll
see you guys next time.
- Cheers.
- Hey.
- To Julia!
- To Julia! (laughs)
(upbeat music)